welcome to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast in today's
episode Greg and I field a number of
questions from listeners pertaining to
the superiority of machines versus free
weights the importance of exercise
variety in the training program what
makes someone a hardgainer and what they
can potentially do about it
some interesting physiological roles of
bone and much more to finish off the
episode we provide some advice for
aspiring students and future researchers
in the field of exercise science and
potentially related fields as well
remember if you'd like to get your
questions answered on a future Q&A
episode be sure to go to tiny dot CC
slash SBS QA and you can submit those
questions there as always thanks for
listening and enjoy the show welcome
back to another Q&A episode of the
stronger by science podcast this is your
host Eric Trexler and today I'm joined
by special temporary guest host named
Greg knuckles thanks for having me on
thank you for joining me today what do
you say we dive right into some
questions well I think first for our
American listeners happy Thanksgiving
this is gonna air one week after
Thanksgiving wait our last episode airs
on Thanksgiving yeah you know what happy
belated Thanksgiving and happy early
Christmas absolutely that's really kind
of you and I was talking to somebody on
the internet today pretty a lot of cool
people on the internet by the way if you
haven't checked it out but they asked if
we were gonna put out an episode on
Thanksgiving Day and I said yes and I
thought that would be a good family
tradition for everybody by the time you
hear this you missed your opportunity
but from now on every Thursday morning
of Thanksgiving you get the new episode
of the podcast you listen with your
family I think that would be fun just
some some background noise as you're
finishing you know prepping the meal for
the day hopefully will distract people
enough that they don't get on the topic
of politics maybe just make the whole
day run better I don't know I think it's
usually good for people to really get
into the politics and dig into some of
these issues a lot of fruitful
conversations come from that sure
all right so hopping into it we're gonna
start with a question for Eric from Jade
Jade asks are there negatives of in
taking too much protein is the one gram
of protein per pound rule good if I'm
trying to build a lot of muscle should I
be taking in more than that yeah that's
a good question it comes up a lot it
seems to be really common that people
are concerned about excessively high
protein intakes and and potential health
issues resulting from that so first of
all let's talk theory when you go on the
internet you're gonna see people saying
all sorts of bad things about protein
some of the common ones you're gonna
hear one relates to the kidneys a lot of
people say the kidneys are going to be
unable to sufficiently clear the waste
products that are made during amino acid
metabolism and that the kidneys are
going to be unable to neutralize the
acid load resulting from high intakes of
amino acids and so by extension people
say high prote high protein diets are
bad for the kidneys themselves and an
offshoot of that people will promote
something called the acid ash hypothesis
which is that if you have a high protein
diet you'll be in this kind of systemic
state of acidosis and that will cause
bone loss as a a mechanism to deal with
that acidosis and promote buffering so
those are two things that are repeated
very frequently when you talk about
high-protein diets but they're really
not accurate they're not true if you
have a pair of healthy kidneys you
should be more than able to accommodate
a high-protein diet so the idea that
you're going to cause direct kidney
damage as a result of protein intakes
within the ranges that we've actually
studied which you could argue go up to
even above 3 grams per kilogram per day
which is a lot of protein and beyond I
mean we've seen studies up into the four
range that have at least found people to
be generally okay so basically your
kidneys should be able to handle about
as much protein as you would want to
eat once you start going above those
levels of protein intake that's just not
a very fun diet and and I can't think of
a reason why you would ever intend to go
that high with your protein intake now
when it comes to the acid ash hypothesis
the idea of losing bone mass as a result
of high protein diets that's been I
think pretty soundly debunked in the
literature and if anything there have
been more recent studies that have shown
that high-protein diets tend to have a
neutral - potentially a positive effect
on bone content and bone density over
the lifespan so the idea that
high-protein diets are bad for bone it's
not only been debunked but could
actually be wrong in the opposite
direction it's it's very possible that
high protein diets might actually have a
modest positive effect on bone bone
content and density over the lifespan so
the whole kidney family of protein myths
we can pretty much toss those out the
exception being if you have an
underlying kidney pathology you might
want to talk with your physician about
whether or not limiting limiting protein
intake is a good idea for you so
absolutely if you have serious kidney
issues there are some instances where a
high protein diet would be definitely
contraindicated and would really put you
at risk and put your health at risk so
but it's important to separate those two
things out the fact that high protein
diets can be challenging to a diseased
kidney does not mean that a healthy
kidney cannot accommodate high protein
intakes those are two very very
different things a lot of times you'll
hear people talk about potential liver
issues with protein intake
you know the liver is heavily involved
in amino acid metabolism involved in
deamination things like that so the
liver because it's involved with amino
acid metabolism a lot of people kind of
go with an extension of that and say
well if we're asking the liver to do
things maybe we're going to tire it out
and fatigue it and it's going to be
generally bad for it much like with the
kidney
evidence that we have available would
indicate that when we put a healthy
person with a healthy liver on a
high-protein diet their liver seems to
accommodate that completely fine there
was a study fairly fairly recently
within the last couple of years by Jose
Antonio 14 males crossover study for one
year they were studying high protein
diets in the range of two point five to
three point three grams per kilogram per
day for pretty long periods of time that
they were consuming these different
levels of protein intake and they did
look directly at various liver and
kidney biomarkers and found no
deleterious or harmful effects that same
lab they also did a study looking at
intakes up to four point four grams per
kilogram per day again that's just a
horrific Lehigh protein intake yeah
there's really no reason to go that high
you you've essentially maxed out the
benefits of a high protein diet probably
about halfway to that intake you know I
mean yeah anything above two point two
grams per kilogram you're really kind of
reaching maybe you could make the
argument if you're a bodybuilder in
contest prep and you're five and a half
percent body fat and just trying to get
the last couple ounces of glute fat off
maybe you might hang around higher than
two point two or three but yeah four
point four grams per kilogram is gonna
be a miserable time you're gonna be so
full and satiated that you're gonna feel
sick all the time so there's just no
reason to be up there but in any case
they did that study and again they
didn't directly look at liver and kidney
biomarkers to my knowledge but everybody
lived so that's a good sign
yeah but but they didn't have any
serious adverse events reported aside
from just people I don't know if they
mentioned it in the paper but I'm
assuming that people generally felt like
crap at least a few of them one would
think hey yeah so I'm not even go back
and check for that I'm comfortable
saying if we find twenty people and we
put all of them on 4.4 grams per
kilogram at least six are gonna say I
hate this I feel gross all day well I'm
probably only three
actually going to strictly adhere to it
correct yeah
due to that reason yeah so the reality
of the situation is there's a lot of
these myths out there about the kidneys
and the liver and even bone health that
high-protein diets are going to be
deleterious or disadvantageous or even
dangerous and if you are an otherwise
healthy person with no underlying kidney
or liver disease or pathology you should
be completely well equipped to handle
high protein diets
now obviously I'm restricting that to
the levels of intakes that we've seen in
the literature so we've got plenty of
studies above two grams per kilogram
not many above three and only one that I
know above for in humans so obviously if
you're trying if you're trying to make a
point I've said this on the podcast
before I think but my general nutrition
rule is if you do extremely weird things
weird things could happen so if you push
the intake of anything beyond anything
we've ever seen in the literature I
can't rule out the possibility that
something weird might happen but but
within sensible protein intakes
high-protein diets seem to be completely
fine and there are many benefits of high
protein diets so if you're training hard
obviously you want to maximize the
anabolic response to training and you
want to minimize muscle loss during
weight loss so high-protein diets are
terrific for that if you're trying to
lose weight they also have a great
effect on promoting satiety and fullness
they also have a high thermic effect of
feeding so generally speaking whether
you're trying to gain muscle or retain
muscle and lose fat high protein diets
seem to be a good way to go how high
that's a good question
generally speaking most people who lift
weights are going to be just fine in the
1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram per day
range I think a lot of people push one
gram per pound because it's very easy
especially if you're used to do to
dealing with pounds as your unit of
weight measurement but 1.6 to 2.2 grams
per kilogram seems fine if you're a
person who really prioritizes your
weight lifting resistance training
progress endurance athletes might get
away with slight
lower intakes in the 1.4 to 2.2 ish
range but but that should be a good
range to start in and then there are
some special instances like I said very
lean people who are cutting really hard
might venture beyond two point two
that's based on a review paper that our
dear friend the good dr. Eric Helms
wrote a few years ago one final thing I
want to talk about the gift that keeps
on giving
the game-changers documentary they had
this awesome part I'm paraphrasing but
they basically implied that if you ate
meat it would have a bad effect on your
muscle glycogen levels and of all the
half-baked ideas that got kind of lobbed
out during that documentary I think that
was the most harmful to me as a person
and my heart and my brain because I was
like it's just the stupidest thing like
it was operating under this zero-sum
assumption that well if you're eating
meat you're probably on what a 90
percent protein diet I'm sure like
there's no way a person could have meat
in their diet and also have several
hundred grams of carbohydrate per day to
completely replace all the glycogen that
they use throughout the day I mean it
wouldn't shock me if someone did like a
very biased funded study or is like one
group eats a steak and the other group
eats like four cups of rice it's like
which one has higher glycogen ooh the
rice yeah I believe it but yeah so man
it's it's one of those things that like
if that makes it through the editing
process you kind of just take the whole
thing and throw it out in the trash
you're like okay I I've seen what's
going on here so yeah don't worry you
can still eat high-protein diets which
do include meat sometimes and still
manage your muscle and liver glycogen
levels very effectively I mean this
isn't really my area but there's I'm
pretty sure I've seen some research
looking at glycogen replenishment rates
and endurance athletes where they test
just carbohydrate versus carbohydrate
with not like a tremendous
on a protein but carbohydrate plus some
level of protein and if memory serves
those studies tend to find either
similar or slightly superior glycogen
replenishment with carbohydrate plus
protein versus carbohydrate alone you
are correct
cool so yeah it's another instance of
not just being wrong but being wrong
hard in the other direction alright so I
think that I think that answers that
question right I think so ok let's move
on to the next one this one is from
Alastair and the question is so we had
Lauren Cole ENSO simple on the show some
number of months ago I've lost track of
time but she's one of our coaches it
stronger by science and we are talking
about training and she basically
suggested an idea I don't think she was
like you know leaning hard into it it's
not like her main coaching philosophy
that she's about to write an e-book
about or anything like that but she
talked about the value in sometimes
rather than doing like six sets of the
same exercise saying well why don't you
just do one set of six different
exercises and present a more varied
stimulus for the muscle and so the
question here is is there any reason to
believe that changing exercises
circumvents the diminishing returns
effect of doing multiple sets yes oh
that's a good question and it's not one
to which I have a firm answer but what I
will say is that I think that the that
the effect of doing like multiple
different exercises but the same number
of sets I think that the the net impact
of that would either be neutral at worst
or possibly positive the reason I say
possibly positive is that I'm not sure
that it would have an impact on say just
like total lean body mass accretion or
total like arm lean mass accretion or
anything like that but there is some
evidence that varying exercises helps
kind of target all regions of a
particular muscle or all muscles within
a muscle group
effectively so in that statement I think
like five years ago would have been
completely decried as a bro science but
now there's actually a pretty fair
amount of evidence for it so to start
with I think probably the first study
that I bring up when having this
discussion is one from Fonseca and
colleagues and 2014 the title is changes
in exercise are more effective than in
loading schemes to improve muscle
strength and so essentially in that
study they had four groups one of them
so the way that study worked is it was a
training study with volume increasing
over time and in one of the groups what
they did is they kept the exercise the
same the whole time the exercise being
smith machine squats but they varied the
load throughout kind of like an
undulating periodization deal in another
group they kept just the exercise the
same only smith machine squats didn't
vary the load so it was like 80% 1rm for
every session one of the groups they
varied the exercises so they had four
lower body exercises and total smith
machine squats being one of them but I
think also leg press lunges and
deadlifts maybe so two of the group's
they had that variety of exercises one
of them again used varying loads so kind
of like a undulating periodized approach
and one of them just stuck with about
80% 1rm for every session for those four
different exercises and so the the net
result of that study is I want to say
strength gains were pretty similar in
every group or maybe they were better in
the groups that varied exercises I don't
remember that one for sure but this
question is about hypertrophy and I do
remember this one for sure what they
found
hypertrophy wise they were looking at
quad growth and essentially like vastus
lateralis growth and just like
generalized quad growth was pretty
similar in all four groups but the
groups that varied exercises throughout
the study had like better growth in all
four heads of the quads so like general
growth was pretty similar in all of the
groups but the ones that varied
exercises like had more fastest
intermediate group intermedius growth or
vastus medialis growth so like kind of
overall well-rounded quad hypertrophy
favored the groups that varied exercise
even though like generalized quad growth
was probably pretty similar across the
board so that's that's looking at
different muscles within a single muscle
group there's also some research looking
at regional activation with different
exercises targeting the same muscle
group so this is this is the piece that
a few years ago people would have
decried as bro science the idea was
basically you know if you activate the
hamstrings the entire muscle gets
activated and it's probably going to
have a relatively hyper a relatively
similar hypertrophic effect all the way
up and down the length of the muscle
what we found since then is there's kind
of like well essentially just that
regional activation is possible if you
activate the hamstrings like the middle
of the hamstrings muscle the proximal
parts of it the distal parts of it are
all probably going to activate to a
similar degree but based on the
exercises you choose you can have say
greater proximal hamstring activation or
greater distal hamstrings activation
based on the different sorts of
exercises you choose specifically here
like hip extension type exercises seem
to kind of activate the whole muscle
somewhat equally or maybe slightly more
like the proximal parts of the hamstring
like closer to your butt and like knee
extension type stuff seem earth knee
flexion type stuff I mean seems to
activate kind of the distal portions of
it closer to your to the back of your
knee a little bit more but but that's a
that's a generalizable thing that we
found with different exercises in
different muscle groups so by varying
exercise for the same muscle or the same
muscle group you make it a little bit
more well rounded hypertrophy up and
down the entire length of a muscle
instead of just concentrated at the
point that say a particular exercise
would target with regional activation
this is somewhat this is a bit of an
aside
but just to illustrate how plastic
muscle fibers are there was actually a
rodent study which I didn't dig up
before recording this but which Andy
Galpin shared I don't know maybe a year
ago at this point but it was looking at
myosin heavy chain isoform densities up
and down the length of an entire muscle
fiber so essentially like a decent
amount of your muscle fibers aren't just
like pure type 2 or pure type 1 they'll
have like a mixture of type 1 myosin and
type 2 mice and heavy chains and it
found that like the the amount of type 1
versus type 2 myosin heavy chain z' can
actually very up and down the length of
a single muscle fiber which suggests
that like there were probably some some
adaptations going on that would spur
that that like you know maybe the
proximal or the distal part of that
fiber was getting generally more work in
that mouse's day-to-day life
so anyway muscles are pretty plastic and
I do generally think that varying the
exercises you use to target a particular
muscle will probably give you more well
well-rounded growth down the entire
length of that muscle or across that
entire muscle group so as I said to
start with if you're just interested in
just sheer total growth like maybe
muscle volume just as a gross measure of
that entire muscle size I don't know
that varying exercises is going to
affect that so much I kind of think it
will but I'm not sure about that
but I do think it will probably give you
more well-rounded growth again kind of
across the entire muscle and throughout
the entire muscle group and I certainly
don't think it's going to be worse for
total hypertrophy now in terms of how
you accomplish that I don't necessarily
know that you would need to do it the
way Lauren suggested of like you know
maybe using six different exercises for
one muscle group within a workout
instead of just six sets of one exercise
you know it could be you do a four-week
block of one exercise and then you do a
four-week block of another exercise and
then you do a four-week block of another
exercise or it could be you know if
you're training biceps twice a week you
do two sets of three different exercises
on one day and then you do two sets of
three different exercises on the other
day like I don't think that you have to
use all of those exercises within one
session there's there's different ways
you could set that up but I am generally
in favor of like varying the exercises
you use to attack a particular muscle
group again if your primary goal is
hypertrophy if it's strength then you
know you probably don't want to stray
too far away from the exercises you're
primarily using to test strength so if
you're a power lifter you should
probably be doing a fair amount of squat
bench deadlift maybe you have some
variation in there but you know probably
the majority or at least a good bulk of
your work coming from the classical
exercises but if your goal hypertrophy I
think variations generally a good thing
and one other possible benefit as well
is just motivation and here different
people are wired differently some people
want a reasonably small stable of
exercises they do they want to do them
all the time they want to be able to
more directly be able to compare their
performance in this session to you know
the session they just did three days ago
and the session they did four days
before that etc etc but for a lot of
people like variety is the spice of life
and they just don't like to do more
exercises and kind of get bored if they
do the same stuff all the time that
doesn't apply to everyone but it does
apply to some people so just to kind of
wrap this up and bring it home varying
exercises especially doing a bunch for a
single muscle group within one session I
don't know that it's strictly better I
think at worst it's probably about as
good as doing a bunch of sets of just
one exercise but I do think it is
probably at least somewhat beneficial
for ensuring well-rounded development of
the particular muscle group that you're
trying to target
I should be fair here the
example I put forth of doing like six
different exercises in the same workout
that might have been a strawman I simply
don't remember with a great deal of
detail exactly the scenario we talked
about with Lauren so if I made an
egregious exaggerated straw man my
sincerest apologies alright so moving on
next question for Eric I don't see the
questioners name here but the question
is machines versus free weights for
hypertrophy which allows the greatest
volumes and gains with four Z's yes so
there's a reason why I arranged the
questions this way because I think this
question you know we have a little bit
of overlapping referencing so I think
when it comes to machines versus free
weights one of the benefits to me of
machines are that they they allow for
additional variety as you mentioned and
so for some people that variety is gonna
meet their preferences better like you
said some people really enjoy having
that variety I intended to talk a lot
about that study by Fonseca at all that
you talked about with squats only versus
a variety of exercises and I think
that's really a place where machines
shine is if you walk into a commercial
gym setting and you say like yeah I want
to get plenty of leg volume but I don't
want to just like squat until I puke
what's really great is that the machines
offer you a way to target different
muscle groups at different angles get a
more varied stimulus for hypertrophy so
you know the reason I wanted to bring up
that Fonseca study they compared the
squat only versus squat with leg press
dead lifts and lunges obviously only one
of those is a machine but certainly when
you have a commercial gym set up and all
those machines at your disposal you can
imagine that for a given amount of total
number of sets for a leg workout it
really opens up the PlayBook in terms of
you know being able to give a nice
well-rounded stimulus for hypertrophy
and one of the cool things about
beans are another cool thing is the fact
that machines can be used with really
minimal set-up time and without a great
deal of skill or experience you know you
could be working with an online client
who maybe is beginner to intermediate in
skill level and you don't want to assign
them really specialized free late free
weight accessory exercises that either
require a great deal of skill and
balance or they might just not be
advanced enough they might not be ready
for them yet or frankly they might just
be a pain in the ass to set up if so
it's like you know what we could also
just go to a hack squat machine which
hack squat machines are probably among
the most underrated machines that you
could possibly find in a gym nothing
better for the quads than a well-made
hack squat machine so I I think that
machines certainly have a place and I
think one of the things about machines
that is frustrating is that they've
developed such a bad reputation among
the more like hardcore lifters within
certain pockets of the fitness industry
you know there's certainly some some
pretty old-school folks who are
perceived to be pretty hardcore lifters
that still utilize all sorts of machines
you know but I think for a lot of people
they think like you know it's free
weights or bust basically but machines
they should very much be a viable part
of the of the PlayBook that you have at
your disposal and there is a study by
Fabrizio Rossi at all and so Fabrizio I
actually got a chance to meet him when
he was working with jason khalipa down
at Coastal Carolina a really good guy
really good researcher and in that
collaboration with with Jason Kalia but
they did a study looking at squat versus
leg press and I think they had a third
treatment arm which was squat and leg
press and without getting really far
into the details of that study basically
what they found was for most of their
outcomes whether you were squatting leg
pressing or both you were pretty fine
the-the-the the outcomes were fairly
similar specifically when it comes to
the lean body mass changes they were
they were pretty much equivalent with a
three of those groups
the functional outcomes varied a little
bit and obviously when it comes to
exercise specificity is a very important
consideration so there there are
certainly some physical tasks where you
can't just throw out in the squat and
say whatever I'm gonna leg press instead
right specificity absolutely is
important to keep in mind but when it
you know the question was specifically
about hypertrophy I think with
hypertrophy I I don't think it's fair to
say that machines are better than free
weights and I think certainly you would
want assuming that you have you don't
have any constraints in terms of
injuries or skill level
I still think you want to build the base
of your program around compound
movements that are likely to feature a
lot of free weights but I don't see any
reason to consider free weights to be
unequivocally superior to machines when
the machines are utilized well within
the context of the program so my advice
to people when it comes to getting in
your volume to promote the hypertrophy
you're looking for just understand that
free weight and machine exercises are
all on the table I think for most people
a combination of the two is going to
make a lot more sense than going really
hard in one direction or the other you
can do just fine in terms of hypertrophy
if you're going machines only and you
can do just fine for hypertrophy if
you're going free weights only so I
don't think it's a dichotomy that is
particularly constructive I think you
put together a program you want to make
sure if hypertrophy is the goal you want
to make sure you have sufficient volume
and as we've talked about it might make
sense to make sure you have plenty of
exercise variety in the mix and if some
of those are machines no problem at all
another cool thing about utilizing a
variety of exercises this something
we've touched on before which is kind of
a bit of a tangent but I know for me
anecdotally I'm by no means anywhere
close to an expert on injury or anything
of the sort but if I just hammer a
single lift in the same plane of motion
in the same angle in the same direction
set after set after set day after day
that can reel
bring a little bit of wear and tear to
the joints involved and so sometimes a
nice thing about variety with your
exercise selection whether it's with
machines free weights or both is that
you're hitting things at different
angles loading the joints a little bit
differently and the different tissues
that make up the joint
and it can be a nice a nice beneficial
aspect that you are giving your joints a
little bit of variety as well and not
overloading them the exact same way set
after set after set so that's that's my
take do you have any anything to add
when it comes to machines Greg yeah I
mean I think it I think it largely
depends on what machine you're talking
about and what free weight exercise
you're comparing it to so for example
you mentioned a study comparing squats
versus like press and the thing about
squats and leg press is there are pretty
similar exercises so in both cases they
have a varied strength curve so there's
a part of the range of motion where
you're weaker there's a part of range of
motion where you're stronger and but
they have flat resistance curves so the
amount of resistance a barbell is
pushing down on you with is the same
throughout the range of motion same
thing with a leg press the amount of
force this the sled of the leg press is
pushing into your feet with is the same
throughout the range of motion so those
are are fairly comparable exercises in
terms of comparing strength curve to
resistance curve however if we look at
something like say a PEC fly or a
pullover and compare that to like a PEC
deck or a really high quality pullover
machine I think it could be a little bit
different high perch for you I so if you
do a full range of motion fly you know
it's hard at the bottom by the time the
weights a third of the way up
it's stupidly easy same thing with a
pullover when the dumbbell is below your
head or near head level it's pretty
challenging once you bring it probably
four or five inches above head level
it's super easy
compare that to a PEC deck which is
specifically designed to be able to keep
ten
on your pecs through the entire range of
motion or like we've talked about on
this podcast before both Eric and I love
a well-made pullover machine keeps
really great tension on your lats and
and probably the long head of your
triceps to some degree as well but
really really great tension on your last
through the entire range of motion I
would be a little surprised if a
pullover machine wasn't better for lad
hypertrophy than a dumbbell or an EZ bar
pullover was for lat hypertrophy I'd be
a little surprised if a PEC deck wasn't
a little bit better for PEC hypertrophy
than dumbbell flyes work for PEC
hypertrophy so they have that benefit of
being able to match strength curves to
resistance curves a little bit better or
I guess resistance curves to strength
curves like the way the cam systems are
built that's literally what they're
designed to do and for some free weight
exercises I doubt that matters all that
much because the strength curve is
relatively flat but for some free weight
exercises I do think that could make
quite a bit of a difference and give an
advantage to machines and then another
thing I would say is I very much agree
with with Eric that it's good to have
variety and I think I think sometimes
you're a little bit limited variety wise
with free weights in terms of being able
to pick exercises where you can really
make sure you're going to be limited by
the target muscle and can keep you know
good stress on that target muscle so for
example if you're trying to train your
quads and you're doing freeway to
exercises you have squats and some
variety of squats that's good
where do you go after that Bulgarian
split squats those are okay but until
you get really good at them do you
really want to go to failure cuz you
know you could lose your balance well
okay let's do dumbbell Bulgarian split
squats so if you start losing your
balance you just drop the dumbbells
that's fine but as you get stronger grip
is going to be become a limiter before
quad fatigue is so or you know like step
ups or lunges similar type things like
balance could become an issue or just
getting other muscle
involved could start limiting you before
you actually are able to fatigue the
muscle that you're trying to fatigue but
if you open yourself up to also using
machines to get that variety then you
know you can do hack squats that's
always going to be limited by your quads
or leg press which if you do it
correctly can also always be limited by
your quads
so in that case machines when it
strictly be better but it's more like
you know for for some muscles there is a
tremendous amount of variety you could
achieve with just free weights and for
other muscles you're you're going to be
somewhat limited with really good
exercise selection unless you open
yourself up to to working some machines
in as well that's a really good point
very good addition okay moving on to the
next question this one is from who I how
would you pronounce that
ee to Petter ie to Petter that works for
me okay so the question is we know that
bone mineral density improves with
weight training I was wondering if there
would be any reason to suspect that this
relationship could be to weight like a
two-way street in that purposefully
growing or improving bone mass could
potentially be a way to improve muscle
mass and strength is it possible to even
prioritize bone mass in this way so Jen
the the general premise here we know
that weight training increases bone mass
but is there a chance that purposely
increasing bone mass has a carryover
effect that would be beneficial for
muscle and strength and if so how would
you do it yeah so that's a really good
question
and it's it's a question that I won't I
really want to look into more at some
point so like in terms of my academic
background like the X phase classes you
take focus a pretty fair amount on
muscle they don't focus on bone all that
much you know we learn about how bone
elongation occurs with aging that
osteoporosis is a bad thing and that
you know wolf slow exists for bone
remodeling like that that's essentially
all you learn about bone in an exercise
physiology class if you want if you want
to get into it more you probably need to
take specific courses on bone which
aren't generally assigned and certainly
an undergraduate and probably graduate
level physiology is as well or you just
need to get into like the bone
literature which unless you know a
pretty fair amount about it is hard to
wade into so I have started wading into
that literature because this is
something I want to know a lot more
about but I very well may have a better
answer to this question in a couple
years however I do think I have at least
a somewhat decent answer to it now which
is that I think that is a possibility
that trying to improve bone mass could
also improve muscle mass or at least
increase your potential to add more
muscle mass the reason I say that is
there is a lot of cross talk between
muscle and bone one of the reasons why
there's not as much bone stuff in basic
physiology textbooks is bone is one of
those tissues where until like somewhat
recently and I don't mean like the last
two years but more like the last 10 20
years people thought that bone was more
or less inert they knew that it could
remodel itself but they didn't know that
it had huge impacts on the rest of the
body
now that now we know that you know bones
produce hormones that can affect a wide
variety of things throughout the body
the the changes in bone metabolism can
drive different hormones in different
parts of the body like parathyroid
parathyroid hormone etc and so like we
now know that bone is a lot more
metabolically active and hormonal II
interesting than we used to so that
stuff is in the literature now but it
hasn't been around long enough to make
it into a lot of textbooks interestingly
the other tissue that kind of meets that
description is adipose tissue people
used to think that adipose tissue was
essentially inert you just you know
stored fat
least fat and that was about it now we
know that adipose tissue does a lot of
very interesting stuff as well but again
that hasn't been known long enough to
really filter into the textbooks but
anyway so bone is metabolically active
it
it affects signaling pathways throughout
a lot of the body and there's quite a
bit of cross talk between muscle and
bone and so it is very plausible that
stuff going on in the bone could affect
the muscle as well if there's some sort
of regulator for like bones to protect
themselves that could pretty clearly
affect like how much muscle your body
will let itself accrue insofar as like
when your muscles contract that puts a
tremendous amount of compressive force
on your bones and so like maybe if your
bones just aren't strong enough they
send signals to your muscles to say like
hey dudes like stop getting bigger and
stronger or bad things are gonna happen
I'm not saying that happens but that
would be an incredibly plausible thing
to happen just as a protective mechanism
another kind of interesting thing to
throw in there is Frances hallway who
was interviewed for the book the sports
Jean he has it's not really like a
proprietary algorithm but he has he has
a big database of various athletes
muscle to bone ratios so that's not
that's not like dry weight of a bone
which is essentially what you get if you
got it DEXA but it's like a big
anthropometric row metric measurements
and use that to estimate the wet weight
of bone someone has in their body and in
this big huge database he has he finds
that essentially elite athletes in a
wide variety of different sports seem to
get to a muscle to bone ratio of
essentially five to one and then past
that point you see very very few people
who have more muscle than that in
relation to how much bone they have so
that again lends some degree of evidence
to the idea that maybe the amount of
bone you have can constrain how much
muscle you can grow
something else we've talked about on the
podcast before is just the general
observation that active kids tend to
have higher muscle and strength
potential than like kids who grew up
more sedentary again there's no research
on that but that's an observation I've
had and I think a lot of other people
have had as well and so kids who are
more active wind up with more bone
mineral density by the time they're
hitting puberty and adulthood so maybe
there's some sort of relationship there
as well
and then in terms of just the
directionality of the relationship of
muscle influencing bone and bone
influencing muscle obviously muscle
influences bone tremendously like I said
before muscles contract that puts a lot
of compressive force on bone that causes
bone remodeling helps bones get thicker
and stronger like that is a well-known
directionality of that relationship but
there's actually some evidence that
probably metabolically to some degree
bone might be affecting muscle more than
the other way around so there was a
20-17 study by Yoshimura and colleagues
title is is osteoporosis a predictor of
future sarcopenia or vice versa
four-year observations between the
second and third road study surveys and
so this isn't this is like the opposite
of hypertrophy and gaining bone mass
this is like you know losing muscle mass
and bone mass but looking to see like
what the primary direction of influence
is there and so in this study what they
found is that developing osteoporosis
was a statistically significant
predictor of then also developing
sarcopenia but the opposite relationship
wasn't true developing sarcopenia was
not a statistically significant
predictor of developing osteoporosis now
I should note in this study it very much
seemed like the direct like the
relationship worked in both directions
so the adres the odds ratio for
osteoporosis predicting sarcopenia
was 2.99 and for sarcopenia predicting
the development of osteoporosis it was
2.11
the difference though in terms of the
strength of the prediction is that the
confidence interval for osteoporosis
predicting sarcopenia was quite a bit
tighter than the confidence interval for
the opposite relationship so so that's
where they kind of that's where they
derived the conclusion that osteoporosis
was a stronger predictor and therefore
possibly more causative of sarcopenia
than sarcopenia being more causative of
osteoporosis it is probably still a
two-way relationship like don't get me
wrong just if like if you could perform
a magic experiment or like if you could
perform magic and just take a group of
people and say now you have no muscle
mass their bones are gonna go downhill
quickly and if you could also do the
same thing and say hey now you have no
bone mineral density their muscle mass
and muscle strength is also going to go
downhill quickly so like this
relationship definitely works in both
directions but this study is saying that
the strength of that relationship is
probably more so in declining bone
health affecting muscle health more so
than declining muscle health affecting
bone health so it very well could be the
case that that sort of directionality of
that relationship also applies to
gaining bone mass and gaining muscle
mass that you know your muscles get
stronger it helps your bones it could
also be that getting your bones stronger
and healthier helps your muscles maybe
to a slightly greater degree than the
opposite way around we don't know that
for sure yet but it is at least
plausible that's all I'm trying to do in
this question I'm not saying this is a
for-sure thing I'm just saying it is a
plausible thing and I do think it is
quite plausible so then the question is
if all of that is true if we assume that
that's all true what are ways you could
go about trying to prioritize and
improve gaining bone mass and bone
mineral density to improve muscle mass
and strength one of the big ones is just
keep training
heavy resistance exercise is good for
improving bone mineral density and
certainly for preserving it as you age
if you want to go above and beyond that
though the two things that come to mind
immediately for me at least would be
possibly doing heavy partials just
getting overload on your skeleton and if
you go that route I would recommend not
going crazy with it at first you know
probably doing stuff through a slightly
shortened range of motion that would
maybe allow you to lift 10% more weight
than you would otherwise be able to I
wouldn't recommend doing like super
super partial range of motions with
twice as much weight as you can move
through a full range of motion that
would probably be overkill but yeah
partials might do the trick
I'm not sure but that is possible and
the other thing that would come to mind
is plyometrics plyos just because
there's the shock of like absorbing the
forces you hit the ground that causes
quite a bit of stress to the bone and
that also causes bone remodeling so
partials and plyos would be probably my
two suggestions of if you wanted to do
something on top of just normal heavy
resistance training to try to improve
bone health further it's a little bit
off topic did you happen to see that
paper the thing was a month or two ago
indicating that bone played a
particularly important role in the
fight-or-flight response
I did yeah I didn't did you read the
paper at all I skimmed it yeah I read
the title and I said a better version of
me would stop and read that paper but I
was very busy at the time so I haven't
checked it out yet I mean the the paper
came out right when all of us were like
trying to finalize mass for the month
yeah I'll do it but it's a it's
definitely on my radar and it if memory
serves that paper kind of spoke to one
of the things I mentioned before that
like I want to say that paper was
talking about how like bone can
influence thyroid hormone output which
is then like part of the fight-or-flight
cascade I know
remember that for sure but yeah I mean
bone does a lot of a lot of crazy [ __ ]
like way way more than probably 90% of
people listening to this podcast are
aware of and way way more than the
scientific community knew about even
five or ten years ago yeah in a future
episode we're gonna have an interview
with somebody I'm gonna keep it secret
for now
but we talked about there's also a paper
indicating that there might be some type
of bone some kind of mechanism by which
bones can sense how much we weigh and
potentially provide some feedback when
it comes to body weight regulation there
have been some really intriguing studies
done in mice where they implant external
loads basically and see how that affects
their ability to control and manipulate
their body weight with some really
shocking results so I think we're really
we're really just starting to understand
like oh wow that whole thing that keeps
our body together it also seems to do
other things aside from just being
scaffolding so it'll be exciting to see
to see where it goes from here but there
there's certainly several active lines
of research that are gonna pick up
alright so moving on next question for
Eric is from someone who is named or
goes by skinny okay so the question for
Eric is do quote-unquote hardgainers
benefit from exceeding one gram of
protein oh yeah
so this is another one about high
protein I thought it was just read
reading a question do hardgainers
benefit from exceeding one gram of
protein per kilogram of bodyweight does
that ramp up signaling in any meaningful
way side question do you see much in the
literature about quote unquote hard
gainers who are female using scare
quotes because according to the internet
some folks question the premise of hard
gainers existing at all
alright so my answer for skinny i'm sure
that the name skinny has nothing to do
with the subject matter of the question
asking about the asking about hard
gainers okay so I view this as more of a
hard
Gaynor question than a protein question
because well it'll become apparent as we
go here but I just saw one gram per
pound and got scared yeah it's like [ __ ]
scroll to the wrong part of the outline
no that makes sense so let's work our
way backwards hardgainers in in quotes
here is there such a thing there might
as well be okay so what I mean by that
is there is certainly a segment of the
population that struggles when they try
to intentionally gain weight so whether
there is a singular thing that defines
that I'm not necessarily worried about
that at this time what's more important
is we've got this group of people who
struggles to gain weight and would like
to so clearly that is a thing that
exists and I've basically broken it down
into three potential groups of people
who are struggling to put on the amount
of muscle that they would like to gain
okay so let's go with group number one
you might consider yourself a hard
gainer if you try to do caloric
overfeeding you know you try to increase
your caloric intake significantly but
you find that even when you are adherent
to a higher caloric intake you don't
really seem to gain as much weight as
you would expect and it's very possible
that you might be a person who has a
large increase in energy expenditure
when you intentionally over feed this is
a thing that has been documented in the
literature it's not you know some
imagination-based thing I mean this is a
real thing that's been documented what
we know about this is it's highly
variable between individuals so there
have been studies that have really tried
to probe at this variation between
people this variability and basically
take a big group of people over feed all
of them by the same amount and basically
just see do they all gain weight at
approximately the same rate when we
control as much as we could possibly
control and the answer is unequivocally
no some people do have adaptive
responses to over feeding
to help them defend their current body
weight and make them more resistant to
weight gain than others they're not
immune to weight gain
they're just a little bit more resistant
okay that's a big distinction so if
you're one of these people you might
find that overfeeding you you simply are
just adapting to it by increasing your
energy expenditure completely
unintentionally it's outside of your
control but it is a thing that happens
off the top of my head I'm pretty sure
that there's research examining this
effect in both males and females I would
be stunned if it was all done in males
but I would also be stunned if it was a
perfect 50/50 split because what you see
in several lines of research in this
general area and we've talked about this
in exercise science people like to do
studies with male subjects there's in
many in many research areas there is a
discrepancy you know where they're you
know female research subjects are
underrepresented in a lot of these
studies however I'm pretty sure this
body of research includes both male and
female studies or at least studies with
mixed biological sexes in the sample
just looking at like increases in muscle
protein synthesis with increased protein
intakes know looking at increases in
energy expenditure with increased
caloric intakes oh yeah okay so I'm
virtually certain that there's at least
some mixture of male and female research
in this particular area and I see
absolutely no reason why why it would be
something that occurs in only one sex
and not the other just I can't think of
a mechanism that would explain that so
my my hunch is when it comes to you know
the question was does this are there
female hardgainers basically here's my
hunch this is completely shooting from
the hip Greg let me know if you disagree
I think we just see a smaller number of
females talking about it on the internet
and so then the perception is that it
you know might affect males more than
females I think
really is an issue where our perception
of who's affected by this is not truly
indicative of a biological difference
well I mean it probably also interacts
with societal expectations to some
degree laughs absolutely most of the
time I would think since at least not
like all culture but gym culture at
least is telling men like hey B is big
and jacked as possible if you're having
a problem with that
that probably feels very acute and so
you get online you're like what can I do
about this there are absolutely women
who also want to get as big and strong
and jacked as possible but that is not
as much the expectation so if you are a
female quote-unquote hard gainer you're
probably less likely to see that as a
bad thing because it in more conforms
with societal expectations so like I
think you're probably not wrong if if
there is common probably a greater
percentage of them see that as a good
thing versus something like a problem to
be solved absolutely and like I said
like if you're if you're someone who's
trying to gain weight and you're
frustrated that it's it's more difficult
than you expected that is an extremely
relatable thing it's frustrating when
you're trying to impose any kind of
training adaptation or dietary
adaptation lose fat gain muscle get
stronger
whenever you run into friction that's
extremely frustrating so it makes sense
that you'd go on the internet and say
hey what's going on here am i different
how do I fix this but I do suspect that
because of some of those societal
expectations that we just hear about it
more from males than we do from females
and I should be clear that to
acknowledge these societal factors is
not to support these societal factors
you know I've always been in the opinion
whatever body composition goal you have
for yourself you should go for it
regardless of what other people expect
of you so no matter who you are no
matter what people expect you to do if
you want to get strong powerful fast
huge shredded whatever you want to do
you should go for it
okay now
there's another kind of hard gainer I
would and again this is just kind of an
informal definition but I'm trying to
think of what might you be running to if
you're running into if you're a person
who's struggling to put on muscle or
gain weight maybe you are a person who
just has a relatively poor response to
resistance training
you know I'm we've seen this in
different hypertrophy related studies
where they try to look at you know we
put all these people through the same
protocol here do we see variation and
how much muscle gets gained and the
answer is absolutely we do we see pretty
pretty broad variation I saw dr. Brandon
Roberts gave a really good talk about
this down in Mexico about the
heterogeneity in responses to resistance
training you hate to say it but
unfortunately some people don't respond
as well to a hypertrophy program as
others however if if you're in that
situation extra protein is not going to
solve that problem you know so the root
of the question here is do hardgainers
benefit from going over that that kind
of traditional protein recommendation
well if you're a hardgainer because you
have this big adaptive increase in
energy expenditure more proteins not
going to solve that in the same way I
mean if you're not eating enough it
probably won't hurt right but we're
talking about adding going beyond one
gram yeah I know I'm just trying to make
that clear so you started the question
quite a bit ago yeah like you know if
you're not responding well to training
and you're eating 40 grams of protein
per day eating more very well probably
will help in that situation absolutely
if you're already eating what would
generally be considered a sufficient
amount yeah it's probably not gonna help
much yeah so we've talked about a couple
of different potential reasons you'd run
into this one might be you have a big
adaptive increase in energy expenditure
one might be that you're simply I don't
want to say a non-responder but a
below-average responder to high perch
free hypertrophy related training
programs and whether you're in one group
or the other going beyond
one gram per kilogram per day of protein
is not going to be I'm sorry is that
that must mean one gram per pound right
yeah III have to assume yeah we could
have just been working with completely
wrong assumptions this entire time
so the yeah the question asks 1 gram of
protein per kilogram of body weight that
has to be asking about one gram per
pound I'm thinking so so yeah you will
benefit from going above 1 gram per
kilogram yeah the the question is you
know I talked about in my previous
answer my first answer of the day the
ideal range for most people is going to
be somewhere between one point six to
two point two grams per kilogram the
question is if you're a hardgainer
I'm making the question if you go beyond
that range is that going to solve your
problems not if you have an adaptive
increase in energy expenditure the
solution to that is just more calories
if you just genetically are not you just
don't respond well in terms of
hypertrophy aside from just doing your
best with your diet and doing your best
with your training stimulus going to
some extra high protein intake again is
not going to solve that that issue the
one the one area where it might make
sense to start going toward a slightly
higher protein intake the only one that
I could kind of put together as a
hypothetical is if you are getting up
there a little bit in terms of age I
don't know where exactly where the
cutoff is for this but you know a lot of
a lot of the times when they do these
protein studies and what they call older
adults we're talking I think 60s and
Beyond is that right yeah one of the one
of the things about Exercise Science
Research is we talk about groups that
are underrepresented so we've already
mentioned on this podcast females are
often pretty considerably
underrepresented and Exercise Science
Research compared to males I think maybe
the most underrepresented demographic
though is middle-aged people because
you'll see a ton of studies on folks who
are you know 18 to 25 years old in there
in the university Andes
subjects to get a hold of you see a lot
of stuff on people who are 60 years old
and up just because like geriatrics and
sarcopenia osteoporosis research there's
a lot of funding and that there is
precious little research on people aged
say like 30 to 55 yeah so in terms of
you know we see a difference between
young subjects and people who are 60
plus and then the question is when do
these things start switching thing is we
don't know because there's there's so
little research on those in our me those
intermediate age ranges yeah but what
I'm getting at is there there is a line
of research looking at something that
they call anabolic resistance and so I
like I said I think most of the research
I think it's usually 60s 70s 80s and
Beyond where they look at this this
concept of anabolic resistance but
basically the same dose of a high
quality protein doesn't elicit the same
maximal response as it did when you were
younger once you start getting up there
in years and so if you're a person who
is in that kind of age range and you're
like you know what I feel like I should
be getting more of a hypertrophy
stimulus than I am that is the scenario
in which it might make sense to say
maybe we try to push the protein a
little bit higher it's possible that you
know one of the things that happens with
aging as we become a little bit
resistant to the the anabolic stimulus
from protein intake in the diet it might
make sense then to to try a little
increase in protein intake maybe even a
little bit beyond that 2.2 grams per
kilogram per day but for the vast
majority of people who kind of self
identify as a hard gainer I don't think
going beyond 2.2 grams per kilogram is
going to be a viable solution I think
what you really ought to be focusing on
is controlling energy intake and energy
expenditure to do whatever you can to
get into a caloric surplus and I should
mention there's probably another group
of people that the reason I don't bring
this up much is because it's pretty far
outside of my area of X
I think some people they're brain wiring
in terms of appetite control just
functions at a thousand percent yeah I
think there are some people that once
they get into positive energy balance
their appetite
absolutely disappears and I think it
probably has to do with the the brain
pathways associated with appetite
control and we actually have we have a
great article about that in the December
issue of mass coming up with someone who
actually does have expertise in this
area so I know as much as I learned from
reading that in the review process but I
do think that some people that
identifies hardgainers maybe they aren't
a poor responder to training maybe they
don't have a huge adaptive increase to a
caloric surplus but maybe when they
start trying to implement a caloric
surplus their appetite just disappears
and they simply cannot adhere to it just
because they feel gross and full and
again in that situation it's how do we
get creative about getting into a
caloric surplus and usually it comes
down to let's eat some extremely
calorically dense extremely palatable
foods that just go down easy and don't
fill you up I'm gonna just kind of walk
a trebuchet up to the line that we
shouldn't cross in this podcast and just
vault myself completely far over it
Oh God what are you gonna say this is
something else that could make an impact
is medication like oh so we're not gonna
recommend anyone change their
medications or dosages or anything like
oh okay I thought you're gonna go but
what one of the things that I've come
across several times training clients
especially younger men is if they got a
ADHD diagnosis when they were young and
they're on Ritalin or adderall they have
a lot of those same symptoms that you
were just describing with like you know
appetite regulation where you know they
basically have to choose between you
know taking the pills their doctor told
them to and being able to function the
way they want to in day-to-day life
and not being able to eat anything or
just feeling like garbage if they do or
you know going off their pills and then
having a really tough time functioning
in day to day life but then gaining
muscle so you know making no
recommendations about that in any way
shape or form but that that is that is
something that probably a fair amount of
people like a non-negligible amount of
people listening to this might be able
to relate to as well yeah but that's a
very very good point when you said
you're about to cross a line we
shouldn't cross I was like is he going
to the irresponsible line or is he going
to the offensive line and I'm so glad
you went the irresponsible
I feel really good about that one other
thing just a note as well and I I do
think that this is something we're
qualified to talk about is you mentioned
that people with anabolic resistance
specifically older people might benefit
from higher protein doses one thing to
note is that that may actually not even
apply to that many members of our
audience who are older reason why is
that there was a study I don't have it
in front of me right now but there was a
study published like just last year out
of the godforsaken Netherlands that was
looking at this one of the things they
noticed was that all of this research
looking at anabolic resistance with
aging was published mostly in the US and
I think one study in Canada both the US
and Canada largely are car cultures we
don't really walk around all that much
so if you don't have a physically active
job and you don't intentionally go out
and do exercise you're probably pretty
sedentary versus a lot of Europe they
don't have as much of a car culture
there's more mass transit there's
generally like greater packing together
of people so you walk around more to the
shops into people's houses and etc and
so they did a similar study on a older
Dutch population and found that in that
group there was no anabolic resistance
which led them to speculate that you
know maybe it's not so much an inherent
feature of aging or if it is
an inherent feature of Aging maybe it
like quote-unquote naturally would
happen at like 80 years old or 90 years
old versus like the 60s that you know
the current research would support but
it's more just like you know by the time
Americans and Canadians get to sixty
years old there
they've been sedentary for decades and
they're in really bad shape and so
they're having anabolic resistance
whereas you know I would assume most of
the sixty year olds listening to our
podcast are probably into physical
culture in some way shape or form and
very well could still respond to protein
intake just as you did when you were
younger
sounds like some Dutch propaganda to me
that's also incredibly possible I
wouldn't put it past them you can't
trust the Dutch
alright should we move on let's do it
okay so here's the question from share
Wow I think that's our first celebrity
that's ever chimed in with a question
hell yeah have we had one before I don't
think so Cher
love your work okay here's the question
the current literature doesn't provide a
concrete upper limit for the amount of
protein synthesis that you can generate
following a single training session
however it is generally accepted that
doing too much well not necessarily
yield better results in the form of more
muscle protein synthesis and it could
even potentially be detrimental due to
accumulating muscle damage from such a
large training stimulus in a single
session is it possible to speculate that
the diminished return from training too
much can partly be explained by the
muscle protein breakdown exceeding the
maximum muscle protein synthesis that
your body can generate in a single
session yes so that that's a really good
question and just kind of parsing it
here question asks can it be partly
explained by muscle protein breakdown
absolutely the more interesting question
I would say is to what degree is that
you know is that the causative factor
and what other things might be in play
so to start with as cher alluded to we
don't really know there hasn't been much
acute research really looking to see the
full dose-response muscle protein
synthesis per session training volumes
so there's there's one study that gets
cited a fair amount that looks at one
set versus three sets more muscle
protein synthesis with three sets cool
you know those are still both pretty low
volumes I haven't seen anything
comparing say three sets to five sets to
ten sets to 20 sets in humans however
there is a study in mice that cited a
pretty fair amount where
they compared different different set
volumes of resistance exercise in mice
all the way from one set up to 20 sets
and what they saw is that in our furry
little counterparts muscle protein
synthesis plateaued after about five
sets of resistance exercise so and at
that point muscle protein synthesis and
very various anabolic signaling
molecules tended to Plateau
I think mTOR kept ramping up but most of
like the downstream targets of mTOR and
mps itself generally plateaued but
didn't decrease after five sets however
so I'm not saying five sets the magic
number in humans because it isn't mice
that would be wildly irresponsible but
you know I do think that we would
probably see that same general type of
relationship in humans so I think that
you know obviously if there is a a per
session set volume where MPs plateaus as
you do more sets that is going to cause
more and more stress to the muscles that
is probably going to cause you know
damage which then those proteins are
going to have to be broken down and then
rebuilt that's where a lot of the muscle
protein breakdown comes from you're
gonna get local inflammation there's
gonna be some additional muscle protein
breakdown due to the inflammatory
response so those things are going to
ramp up but I'm somewhat skeptical that
that acute muscle protein breakdown is
going to be sufficient to completely
overwhelm the muscle protein synthesis
Ephrem training so like when you look at
increases in muscle protein synthesis
after training they're huge like a multi
fold increase over baseline and in
studies that look at acute muscle
protein breakdown after training it
increases but not to the same degree
that you see synthesis increasing so on
one hand I do think that it is entirely
plausible that you
could do a high enough level of training
volume in a session that muscle protein
breakdown acutely massively overwhelms
muscle protein synthesis however I think
that's also probably going to be quite a
bit beyond the point that you started
getting plateauing results so just to
kind of put some random numbers on it
let's say five sets is the Goldilocks
number where you've maximized muscle
protein synthesis but you haven't done
any extra sets yet you'll get some
muscle protein breakdown from that then
let's say you did eight sets maybe you
get slightly worse results maybe get a
little bit more muscle protein breakdown
but acute MPs is still going to be a lot
higher than acute muscle protein
breakdown once you hit the point that
you're like plateauing and it's so much
that you know you're not longitudinally
gaining muscle anymore I still think
you're going to see acutely muscle
protein synthesis being above muscle
protein breakdown by the time you get to
the point where on a per session basis
mps equals MP b and say like the 24
hours following that training session
like on an acute basis you're probably
at that point just massively overdoing
per session volume and just Hemery
hemorrhaging muscle off of your body so
essentially like i said to answer like
the text of the question can muscle
protein breakdown partly explain these
diminishing returns we see with higher
and higher volumes yeah probably but for
like the acute muscle protein breakdown
to fully explain it you need to be doing
outrageous amounts of volume one of the
things we see however when we look at
the overtraining literature is that we
see changes in global hormone levels we
also see changes in global inflammatory
status recent study that just came out
in the past month or two found that
androgen receptor density decreased in
muscles in an overtrained state so what
i think is much much more likely is that
what's going on like why we see the
diminishing returns and potentially even
atrophy if volume gets too high is yeah
maybe
acute elevations and muscle protein
breakdown play a small role but I don't
think it's gonna play a huge role
because in trained lifters you have
repeated bouts effect type adaptations
that help protect against a fair amount
of damage and thus muscle protein
breakdown so that's probably playing a
small role but not a huge role I think
what's more likely to explain it is that
kind of baseline levels of muscle
protein synthesis versus muscle protein
breakdown change so in completely
untrained lifters who say you know
aren't in the period of their life where
citizens is a big factor yet you know
let's let's say you're 25 years old
you're untrained you're not doing
anything on a day-to-day basis just
baseline levels of muscle protein
synthesis versus muscle protein
breakdown probably gonna be pretty even
in trained lifters if you don't train
muscle protein breakdown is going to be
a little bit higher at rest than muscle
protein synthesis at least when averaged
over the course of a day that's why
you'll slowly atrophy if you don't keep
training so what's most likely is that
when you're in like an overtrained state
and you're doing excessive volume you're
like per session training rashad
response is probably still net anabolic
but you're not in the gym 24 hours a day
and so kind of that baseline muscle
protein synthesis 2 muscle protein
breakdown ratio it's probably shifted
more in favor of just higher levels of
muscle protein breakdown at rest lower
levels of muscle protein synthesis at
rest and that's probably the bigger
driver than just like acute muscle
protein breakdown from excessive per
session volume that is what I think is
is probably most likely to be happening
in a scenario like that now one thing
I'll note is that it is physiologically
possible for muscle protein breakdown to
just massively exceed synthesis and to
that caught in for that to cause like
say Riddick
Heelys amounts of for that to be
associated which is massively ridiculous
amounts of muscle damage and massively
prolonged declines and muscle functions
so for example if you take completely
untrained lifters and have them do like
just a really sadistic maximal eccentric
training protocol you'll often see
you'll often see or there's some studies
that look at recovery up to a week after
the initial training impulse and you'll
see that a fair amount of the people
still aren't recovered a week later and
so like and we're still and we're
talking like 10 20 percent reduction in
force output after a week of recovery I
don't think those studies are also
taking biopsies to look and see like oh
did my referral or protein also decrease
but in a situation like that where
you've had a week to recover from a
training impulse and you're still having
like a pretty notable decrease in
performance I think it's very likely
that that training that training you
underwent was so extreme that you did
actually break down more muscle protein
than you synthesized just from you know
one training impulse that obviously
wouldn't be causing overtraining so I do
think I do think the phenomenon you're
asking about is physiologically possible
but I don't think it's hugely relevant
in trained lifters who aren't you know
just 10x in their training volume
overnight I think just kind of shifts in
maybe androgen receptor density maybe
hormones maybe Global inflammatory
status those things are probably more so
shifting baseline muscle protein
synthesis and muscle broked protein
breakdown levels and that's probably
what's causing the decreases in
hypertrophy or actual atrophy over time
much more so than just acute muscle
protein breakdown from muscle damage
after training it makes sense to me cool
final question for both of us is from
cam cam says hey gentlemen hey cam hey
can I have a question related to your
research
podcast where you talk about
recommendations for prerequisites
entering an Exercise Science degree I'm
now five years removed from my
bachelor's degree in kinesiology and I'm
looking to apply to a master's program
in exercise science the problem is that
after five years I haven't stayed in
touch with any professors to the degree
that I would readily ask them for an
academic reference do either of you have
any recommendations on how to seek out a
quality academic reference without being
a complete jerk about it yeah so every
now and then on the Q&A episodes we'll
talk about some kind of like
professional development type thing so
when people have questions about you
know writing or or building a business
we send those greg's way but when you're
in the ivory tower of academia now
you're in my domain okay so I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go first on this one we're
talking about getting recommendation
letters to get into a program I do want
to make this somewhat generalizable so
that other people get some benefit from
this answer so I'm going to answer that
directly and then also talk about I've
had a lot of people reach out to me
asking how to get involved in research
in general so I want to touch on that as
well because they're they're kind of
related here so I would say you really
have two approaches you could take here
when you're trying to get some
recommendation letters for a program
your options are essentially to utilize
relationships you have made in the past
or potentially to make new relationships
that that would that would fit the
criteria so one thing to keep in mind is
whenever you're applying to some kind of
program look to see if they have
stipulations about who exactly is
qualified to offer a letter every now
and then they'll they'll have some very
specific requirements about you need to
letters from this kind of person and one
letter from that kind of person okay so
you'll want to make sure you know
exactly what they're looking for
now if you're going to utilize
relationships that you had previously
formed that you just haven't been in
touch with these folks for a while I
would not hesitate to
contact them at their university you
know email address and basically drop
them a line and get right to the point
and basically say hey I took your class
a while ago I did well in it I enjoyed
it maybe give them a brief reminder of
who you are extremely concise and brief
maybe you attach a resume something
along those lines basically it should be
a single email where they can refresh
their memory I remember who this is they
did well enough in my class or or in the
program here that would warrant me
writing them a recommendation and that
that's key you want to make sure that
they know you know especially if you did
well in their class say here's here's
the grade I got in your class here's my
resume attached here's what I'm applying
for give them all the information they
need and be as concise as possible now I
would suspect that most professors would
be pretty cool with giving you a
relatively lukewarm recommendation
letter with that alone unless you were
just a complete [ __ ] right yeah
that's a big part of the question is
were you terrible because if you were
then they're probably not gonna write it
and then send the email and include as
few details as possible like hey i sat
kind of in the middle of the room I'm an
average looking person if that helps you
place me I I did nothing of interest
except pass my classes please say that
I'm a decent person yeah exactly
so here's the thing for a lot of these
recommendation letters I don't think
anybody is looking for anything
particularly remarkable this is my hunch
being that I lived in the university
setting for about ten years leading up
to this year I don't think that the
recommendation letter is going to in
most cases make or break you obviously
if somebody leaves something that is
particularly terrible that might be
problematic but most people aren't going
to go out of their way to do that they
will actually tell you I don't feel
comfortable writing you a recommendation
letter and when you ask for the
recommendation letter this might sound
silly but somebody told me this one time
and I think it was good advice ask a
person if they would feel comfortable
right
you a positive recommendation letter not
just a recommendation letter ooh here
here's also a recommendation hack so
there was assuming you're American if
you're not American I don't know what
the laws are in your country but there
was a pretty recent federal law like
passed within the last three or four
years where students now have to be able
to see what what people said in their
recommendation letters
so like you can waive that right so when
I applied to grad school I waive that
right I didn't know if that was
something that the grad schools were
going going to be able to see if you
wait for the right or not I was like
yeah it would probably make me look
better as an applicant if I showed that
I was confident enough that I didn't I
didn't need to read this but I'm pretty
sure it's the case that it is your right
to be able to see what they wrote and
generally they're submitted
electronically you just choose to not
waive your right when you apply and you
can see what people are saying about you
so something you could do if you're
willing to like spend a few bucks on an
application is if you kind of think
someone's gonna write you a bad review
or like a bad recommendation you could
just apply to a school you don't
particularly want to get into don't
waive your right to see your letters of
recommendation and just look at the
letters of recommendation and if
someone's writing you a bad one ask
another professor for one like that that
is that's something I'm I'm like 95%
sure you can do yeah I've never thought
of that that's interesting but generally
speaking if you're gonna rely on old
relationships go for the people that
obviously might remember you might have
good memories of you and if possible it
would be great if you could get people
who taught subject matter that was
relevant to the program you're applying
to so if you're applying to exercise
science like a master's degree but you
you get like your history and your
English professors to write those
recommendations that's not necessarily
terrible but it would probably be better
if you got someone who who was teaching
your undergrad kinesiology or at least
loosely related coursework because then
they could speak to your ability as it
pertains to that specific academic
domain like I said it if you had just
absolutely incredible relationship with
a professor from an on an unrelated
course and if there's no specification
that it has to be a certain professor
when it comes to the application
materials if they don't say it has to be
you know an exercise science professor
then obviously if it's a really positive
relationship that that might be a good
option and like I said usually
professors they do so many of these
every single year they pretty much have
a template sitting there and if you can
jog their memory and they say oh yeah
the student was pretty fine they're
probably going to be willing to write
you a quick letter it might not be you
know the most engaging letter it might
not be like please whatever you do let
the student in but they're probably
gonna write you a pretty okay letter
assuming that they don't have any any
axe to grind with you so to speak one
final alternative piece of advice that I
would give is that as Eric said to start
with generally recommendation letters
aren't going to be a make-or-break type
thing if you are a reasonably
competitive candidate like you know your
grades weren't absolute trash your GRE
score or you know if your country has
standardized testing whatever that
standardized test score is at least okay
one thing to keep in mind is that not
all exercise science grad schools are
incredibly competitive
so you know maybe your academics coming
in aren't the best and maybe you're not
gonna get good recommendation letters
and maybe you're gonna get turned down
from your first-choice school but I mean
like I said exercise science masters
programs aren't law school it's not med
school it's not that type of competitive
there are absolutely competitive
programs out there but if you really
really want to go back to school and get
your masters there is probably somewhere
that will take you as long as you're in
just a horrendously bad applicant and
then you know it sucks if you can't get
into your first-choice school but then
as long as you do really really well at
the Masters level and really show out do
good work get good grades develop good
relationships then hopefully that should
open more doors for a ph.d program if
that's what you want to do next or you
know certainly just having those letters
behind your name will open more doors
career-wise for you so you know not the
most optimistic advice but if everything
seems to be stacked against you you can
set your sights lower and somewhere will
probably take you which is better than
you know only applying to your dream
school getting rejected and not doing
anything that is a good point and in one
final point a lot of schools are not
going to expect you to have really close
personal relationships with a bunch of
your undergrad professors you know so
for example my chemistry class in
undergrad I'm pretty sure it had 600
kids in it one time they forgot the
microphone and we didn't even try
everybody went home right there the
microphone doesn't work you're not
having class because it's just not gonna
happen okay so who in that class do you
think developed a really close personal
bond with that chemistry professor
nobody maybe maybe one or two kids that
that absolutely loved the material so
you know you're not expected to have a
ton of extremely close personal
relationships with you know the
professors at your undergrad so even
just a pretty okay letter is gonna be
fine now I did mention at the beginning
of the question another option is to
actually form new relationships okay and
so if you live anywhere near a
university that does have an exercise
science lab that does any kind of
exercise related research or anything
even close to that type of research you
could always start volunteering at a lab
and a lot of people have asked me
unrelated to to application stuff but
they're like I am really into research
how do I get involved the easiest way
is to just volunteer in somebody's lab
that is somewhere you know remotely
close to where you live in my opinion
you know those really positive academic
relationships are formed
sometimes in office hours rarely in the
classroom but very commonly in the lab a
lot of times when you're in the lab
doing that work that the professor is
excited about it's just a more conducive
environment to forming a really close
bond and for them to be in positions
where they had to rely on you or they
had to see you take initiative or they
had to see you just engage with the
material and be really excited about it
those are the memories that are gonna
stick in their head of wow that was a
student who was really dependable loves
the subject matter understands what it's
all about in terms of how this field
works so if you want a really good
recommendation letter you're never gonna
get a better recommendation letter than
the one you get from someone whose lab
you volunteered in regularly that is by
far the best bond you can form when it
comes to you know those strong academic
relationships between professors and the
students in their program so you know
people have asked me like I said how do
I get involved in research volunteering
in a lab is the number one way to do it
now there are other ways to do it you
know there are some people who do
contribute to the research literature
without a ton of hands-on lab experience
and usually what they have to do is
generally speaking they have a master's
degree at minimum and generally speaking
they have built up enough of a
reputation in the field that they are
perceived as an expert so I would say
Greg you you you do have the hands-on
lab experience but you're in that kind
of position where because you've been a
successful writer for so long and people
know your areas of expertise people have
reached out to you to collaborate on on
writing in the academic space and again
you got your your master's degree and
there are other people who have done a
similar thing they're kind of well-known
people with an academic skill set that
are able to contribute to the research
literature because people know what
their skill set is that is a hard road
to pay for yourself obviously you did it
I know of a few other people who have
done it but that's not the not the
typical path to entering the research
world yeah I would put no eggs in that
basket
exactly it takes a unique skill set a
really insane amount of dedication to
that end and luck and some luck so some
people have pulled it off that way I
think a lot of people that ask me like
how do I get into research they think
like that's the the route they want to
go like you know what I mean they're
like oh I want to just have people come
up to me and say hey do research with me
the more typical route is the one I took
which is you go to college for ten years
and do somewhere between 20 and 40
studies and then eventually people will
call your researcher but but yeah so if
you want to get into research the most
likely route to do that is you go start
from the ground floor you go volunteer
at a lab you do honestly the the fairly
low-skilled tasks to kind of pay your
dues and work your way into the lab
eventually you know they start they
typically will start trusting you with
some more skilled tasks in the lab you
start getting more responsibilities you
build that relationship and now you are
officially within the research
infrastructure and as long as you've got
the academic background or are willing
to pursue the academic credentials to
support that now you have officially
worked your way in so I wish that there
was a super easy quick way to do it that
doesn't involve either
spending a whole lot of uncompensated
time or forgoing a lot of income for a
sustained period of time but usually
it's either you do you work your normal
job and volunteer in your free time or
you go the full time student route and
and it's you know you're probably
foregoing some amount of income during
that time so there's no quick way to it
but there are a few very viable paths
if you're willing to to make some of
those sacrifices you think we
sufficiently answered that question I
think we did perfect all right well that
does it that's another Q&A episode for
the stronger by science podcast as
always thank you for listening if you
want your questions answered on a future
episode be sure to go over to tiny dot
CC slash SBS QA thanks for listening to
the stronger by science podcast now Greg
and I are not experts in medicine or
health or really anything else for that
matter so before you make any changes to
your diet and exercise habits make sure
you check with a doctor or another
health care professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science com2 check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]